merci beaucoup d'être notre invité ce
matin bonjour député de l'Essonne
bonjour merci d'être avec nous président
de Debout la France on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice vessarodon du
groupe Evra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
monsieur les journaux de l'Est de la
France on le redit Fabrice on va
évidemment balayer l'actualité avec vous
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan il y a beaucoup de
sujets à voir d'abord Emmanuel Macron
qui était au Mont Valérien hier où a été
annoncé que tous les résistants et
otages fusillés seront déclarés morts
pour la France Emmanuel Macron qui a
également annoncé la panthéonisation en
février prochain demi sac Manouchian
résistant communiste arménien fusillés
en 1944 vous applaudissez cette décision
bien évidemment vous savez quand on va
au Mont Valérien et on ressent toujours
cette tragédie ce sacrifice pour la
liberté de la France
donc il a eu raison Emmanuel Macron
Laurent jacobelli hier qui c'est qui
soutient cette décision dit quand même
regretter qu'elle n'ait pas été plus
partagée c'est votre sentiment aussi je
sais pas vous savez ce genre de décision
qui appartient en président de la
République et qui ne mérite pas débat
aux Français
écoutez il y a suffisamment de motifs de
désaccord profond pour ne pas en
rajouter là où il y a pas de désaccord
vous savez hier soir comme beaucoup de
Français je crois je regardais
cette ce documentaire sur le général de
Gaulle sur une chaîne et quand on voit
je me faisais la réflexion la grandeur
l'intelligence la profondeur des mots
dans les conférences de presse puisqu'il
y avait beaucoup d'extraits je me disais
mon Dieu où nous sommes tombés
et et c'est là où je me suis dit le vrai
problème de la France c'est que
un moment il a eu un mot de général de
Gaulle dans un extrait au moment de la
sortie de l'OTAN enfin du commandant
militaire intégré pour être précis il a
dit on ne peut pas agir en étant
subordonné et bien le drame
d'aujourd'hui je me faisais la réflexion
en regardant aussi les images d'Emmanuel
Macron
honorer les résistants qui sont morts
pour la France bravo mais c'est lui qui
subordonne la France à Bruxelles à
l'OTAN et donc on a si vous voulez un
tel décalage entre la soumission de la
France dans tous les domaines que les
français payent très cher donc
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la France a
toutes les décisions ne sont pas prises
par le Président de la République et
sont prises par Madame vanderleyen elles
sont prises par Monsieur Biden on voit à
quel point la France est dépendante on
l'a vu avec le drame d'Annecy donc moi
je vais vous dire la seule
il y a un coup d'état européen qui se
profile madame vanderleyen sort des
traités elle est sortie des traités elle
se comporte comme si elle était élue
présidente de l'Europe elle n'est pas du
tout élue la Commission de Bruxelles est
en train de piéger la France et tous les
autres pays par des règles
bureaucratiques en matière écologique en
matière de migration en matière
budgétaire donc si vous voulez l'enjeu
aujourd'hui si pour moi en tout cas
c'est mon avis si on veut résoudre les
problèmes français enfin les raisons
parce qu'on les résout pas sur la
sécurité sur l'immigration sur le
développement économique et ben il faut
reprendre notre indépendance et c'est
fondamental moi j'en arrive à la
conclusion en regardant les choses c'est
que jamais la France n'a été autant
subordonnée alors voilà maintenant c'est
l'enjeu libérer la France pour qu'elle
puisse prendre les décisions la
concernant et résoudre ces problèmes
ça peut être sortir s'il n'y a pas de
renégociation possible il y a beaucoup
de pays qui sont comme nous tout le
monde oublie qu'il y a beaucoup de pays
qui ne supportent plus ce coup d'état
permanent comme disait l'autre de Madame
vanderleyen donc je crois que et c'est
ce qu'on a à mon conseil national samedi
on a décidé on a bâti un projet qu'on
présentera aux Français aux européennes
pour dire si on veut régler par exemple
le problème de l'immigration faut sortir
de Schengen oui faut contrôler nos
frontières nationales il faut plus
maintenant hésiter il faut rétablir le
droit national sur les pieds
républicains alors qu'ils ont signé tous
les traités moi au moins j'ai pas signé
ces traités je les ai refusé ils ont
signé tous les traités maintenant ils
nous disent pour venir au droit national
et d'ailleurs ils sont pas tous d'accord
entre eux mais bien évidemment si on ne
reprend pas en main notre politique
d'asile
mais c'est fini il y a plus de France
donc il y a un moment là on est face au
mur voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire
par rapport aux images ambigu du 18 juin
vous rappelez votre attachement
gaullisme une réaction par rapport à ces
six monuments aux morts qui ont été
vandalisés en Martinique à la veille du
de ces commémorations du 18 juin c'est
abominable voilà qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je dis je les condamne bien
sûr totalement je les condamne
totalement
juste un point
il y a des événements comme cela
abominables mais je peux vous dire moi
je vois dans la masse circonscription et
partout il y a une vraie ferveur le
message du 18 juin est profondément
compris et partager par une grande
majorité de Français donc maintenant ce
qu'il faut c'est que les Français
traduisent en acte et que les
gouvernements en actes le message du 18
juin parce que ça sert à rien de
célébrer le 18 juin si on est pieds et
Mali à des intérêts extérieurs sur
l'immigration vous souhaite un
référendum sur les citations vous avez
lancé une pétition pour ça parce que
combien de signatures à l'heure actuelle
je sais pas j'ai pas regardé
mais j'ai écrit le texte de cette
pétition sur internet pour se référendum
suite à Annecy parce que ce qui m'a
effrayé c'est au lendemain de cet acte
abominable de voir le président de la
République à les serrer des mains en
préfecture jouer son rôle de compassion
c'est normal on va lui en vouloir mais à
aucun moment
sentirez des leçons et drame après drame
on ne tire jamais les leçons justement
de l'absence de frontières donc moi je
veux renationalise les demandes d'asile
qu'elle ne valent que pour chaque pays
je veux qu'on contrôle nos frontières je
veux que ça ne recommence pas
éternellement alors on empêchera jamais
bien sûr un drame mais là c'est un cumul
de drame et je vous rappelle que nous
avons le record
de flux migratoire le record en 2022
et la France je voyais le reportage
avant là alors on cache les migrants et
les réfugiés en fait Emmanuel Macron les
caches mais la réalité c'est que la
France et les envoie dans les différents
territoires dans les villages de France
pour les cacher parce qu'il veut pas que
ça se voit à Paris
dans les beaux quartiers bon donc le
problème de fond il y a pas une personne
sensée qu'un peu de tête qui pense qu'on
peut assimiler 500 000 personnes par an
il y a pas une personne qui est pourtant
continue à laisser tout ouvert il y a
900 000 demandes d'asile au niveau de
l'Union européenne mais c'est de la
folie pour eux c'est pas c'est pas nous
contre les migrants c'est pour eux pour
nous c'est pas possible donc soit on
agit
soit on continue comme ça est-ce que ce
qui m'a comment dire ce qui me m'effraie
c'est cette méga
c'est possible de mettre en place que
vous dites à court terme tous les pays
du monde le font le Danemark d'ailleurs
le fait alors qu'il est dur l'Union
européenne tous les pays du monde ont
des frontières sauf nous et c'est le
chaos migratoire donc il y a peut-être
un moment où il faudrait que les
responsables politiques assument leurs
actes moi j'ai voté j'ai retrouvé ça il
y a pas longtemps en triant mes papiers
j'ai retrouvé un texte de 98 je venais
des élus députés ou avec Philippe de
Villiers on était les seuls en 98 il y a
25 ans à dire les demandes d'asile au
niveau européen c'était le traité
d'Amsterdam je m'étais fâché avec
Philippe Séguin à cause de ça parce que
j'avais voté contre
ça peut pas marcher et bien aujourd'hui
on en a la preuve mais en 98 on nous
disait qu'on était ici dans les pays
d'origine pour vous non
les demandes d'asile soit gérées pays
par pays c'est-à-dire que si vous avez
eu la demande d'asile en Suède vous
n'avez pas le droit de circuler c'est là
je veux mettre fin à la libre
circulation des demandeurs d'asile en
Europe je veux que la France retrouve
ses frontières ça sera un des thèmes
majeur des européennes puissent ou à
référendum ça serait merveilleux jamais
les Français ont été consultés
[Musique]
je l'avais fait en 2018 parce que là ça
mène à quoi votre pétition sur le risque
je veux engager et j'espère cette
fois-ci les républicains signeront
puisqu'ils en ont fait donc moi je
signerais l'heure moi vous savez je suis
pas jaloux d'où ça vient
de partager je voterai les textes qui ce
qui ont le les 185 parlementaires je
préfère que ce soit le mien mais je
voterai tous les textes qui permettent
de
traiter la question migratoire même s'il
est texte des républicains ne vont pas
assez loin sur certains points mais
comment vous faites votre trip sur
l'immigration sans changer la
constitution c'est ça la question
l'immigration on le fait le général de
Gaulle a fait par l'article 11 arrêtons
avec ses histoires 89 et d'articles 11
est-ce
établir les frontières nationales faire
vous pensez que le Conseil
constitutionnel va valider
la place des Français ça suffit donc 1
semaine le général de Gaulle l'a fait 62
ça a très bien marché donc un rétablir
les frontières nationales de gérer les
demandes d'asile au niveau national 3
primauté du droit national sont droits
européen tout simplement trois questions
dans votre référendum des manettes oui
reprendre les manettes mais il y a les
Français sont effarés de ce qui se passe
c'est pour ça que la crise politique est
très forte
je vous le dis personne ne comprend
qu'on est à la tête de l'état des gens
impuissants qui ne font que commenter
les choses les drames là c'est notre
survie c'est la vie de nos enfants qui
est en jeu c'est pas la grande politique
c'est la survie des Français contrôler
nos frontières voilà je pense que c'est
clair c'est très clair et vous souhaitez
un projet de loi immigration au mois de
juillet comme Elizabeth
c'est de la régularisation sous prétexte
de métier en tension
des détails des détails pour vous même
la partie du projet de loi gérer par
Gérald Darmanin ce sont des détails je
vais lire les articles et puis tout ce
qui pourra aller dans un sens de
contrôle sera positif vous le vote et
c'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu je
veux vous le dire ce qui se passe en
Europe il y a pas que chez nous
d'ailleurs
dans l'actualité du week-end cette
opposition qui reste vive autour du
projet de tunnel ferroviaire entre Lyon
et Turin les manifestations se sont
poursuivies elles ont reçu le soutien de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon notamment est-ce que
vous pensez qui il faut il faut reculer
sur ce projet réajuster ce projet en
tout cas il mérite d'être examiné des
battues
pourquoi parce que on a des
investissements colossaux à faire en
matière ferroviaire pour notamment des
carboner et ça c'est bien c'est le cas
là cette hypothèse sur ce projet je
pense qu'il faut l'étudier plus avant
pour une raison très simple c'est que
l'argent n'est pas gratuit et qui a des
investissements de proximité très
important à faire dans la région
Rhône-Alpes dans tous les régions de
France le système ferroviaire craque de
partout et je pose juste la question
j'ai pas la réponse est-ce qu'on est
bien sûr que ces dizaines de milliards
sont bien employés et ce qu'on en a
besoin tout de suite c'est la seule
question que je pose j'ai un petit doute
oui mais vous demandez ce gouvernement
de renoncer
un référendum local je crois plus j'y
réfléchi et plus je rencontre des
Français je commence à avoir un peu
d'expérience du moins de mon pays je
crois qu'il y a une vraie crise
démocratique très profonde on l'a vu à
l'Assemblée nationale ou l'assemblée a
été bafoué par la présidente article 40
il y a plus le droit d'initiative
parlementaire à l'Assemblée c'est quand
même gravissime ce qui s'est passé c'est
passé sous silence à travers parce qu'il
y a eu le drame d'Annecy mais c'est
terrible le droit d'initiative c'est
c'est la création de la démocratie en
Angleterre puis la Révolution française
supprimée bon c'est Macron qui décide
les propositions de loi qu'on a le droit
de déposer bon premier problème deuxième
problème on le voit bien réformer cet
article 40 voir elle supprimer vous
souhaitez le travailler puisque il y a
une interprétation
légale mais illégitime qui a été faite
bien évidemment puisque sinon il y a
plus de droit c'est Emmanuel Macron et
Elisabeth Band qui décide ce qu'on a le
droit de voter de débattre enfin c'est
complètement surréaliste qui se passe
mais ça c'est passé comme si net à la
poste deuxième point au niveau local on
voit bien dans nos régions et vous le
savez bien que si on ne fait pas des
référendums locaux des RICS ce qui se
fait aux États-Unis ce qui se fait en
Suisse la crise démocratique va
s'aggraver parce qu'il sait j'en suis
convaincre Dame des Landes ça n'a pas
empêché le gouvernement de faire le
contraire de ce qu'avait dit
problème vous l'avez vu en 2005 avec les
référendum il y a un manque de tradition
démocratique dans notre pays je crois
qu'on débloquera les choses notamment
vis-à-vis de la jeunesse les jeunes
ont des attentes qui ne sont pas prises
en compte aujourd'hui par le pouvoir
politique de tout or et donc je pense
que le seul manière de débloquer le pays
si on prend un peu de hauteur à droite
et de la gauche c'est le RIC référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qu'en Suisse ça
se passe aux États-Unis au niveau des
États au niveau des des comtés pourquoi
pas le faire en France si on ne si on ne
développe pas la société française ça
finira dans le sang moi je vous le dis
vous travaillez avec elle brune Pivet
sur la réforme des institutions puisque
un groupe de travail
mais tout le monde connaît mes
propositions je les ai faites à la
présidentielle Rick réforme européenne
pour faire revenir le pouvoir
démocratique et puis
usage du référendum sur les retraites il
fallait faire un référendum
parlons finances publiques c'est ce
matin qui ont lieu les assise de la
fille des finances publiques
Elisabeth borne va conclure ses assises
face aux déficit à la dette l'État veut
réduire les dépenses ça va dans le bon
sens bah écoutez c'est l'alcoolique
l'alcoolique qui promet de ne plus boire
alors il y a une première mesure je
voudrais qu'elles prennent qui est très
simple possible est-ce que vous savez va
vous le savez que l'État Bercy emprunte
chaque mois entre 1 milliard 5 et 1
milliard 8 à taux variable indexé sur
l'inflation souvent en zone euro vous
savez quand l'État emprunte pour sa
dette il peut emprunter à taux fixe
donc au moins on est sûr de ce qu'on
paiera trois et demi pour cent ou 3% en
ce moment ou alors à taux variable
indexée sur l'inflation
cette faute majeure de gestion depuis
des années a conduit 10% de notre dette
est empruntée à taux variable indexées
sur l'inflation et vous le savez au
budget 2022 on a rajouté 12 milliards
d'euros 12 milliards d'euros pour payer
l'explosion des intérêts liés à cette
faute de gestion et ce qui est terrible
c'est que on peut pas revenir sur ce qui
s'était passé avant encore que c'est
Macron qui l'a fait mais depuis ce qu'on
sait que l'addition est colossale parce
que pourquoi en plein thé à taux
variable très cher quand on peut
emprunter à taux fixe moins cher et bien
il continue tous les mois monsieur le
Maire ça veut dire que là il y a une
économie gigantesque qui pourrait être
faite si on ne faisait pas ce cadeau
scandaleux aux banques et compagnies aux
banques et au marché financier
votre voiture votre maison à tout va
bien mais sur ce qu'on dépense sur ce
qu'on dépense sur ce que l'État dépense
aujourd'hui or cette on a bien compris
or ces années j'insiste parce que sur ce
que l'État dépense sur sa façon
vous le retrouvez dans partout est-ce
que les choses ont évolué est-ce
qu'elles vont évoluer si il y a une
chose qui a évolué
c'est que quand vous êtes citoyen
modeste
vous trinquez quand vous êtes des plus
riches vous avez tapis rouge c'est ça la
réalité c'est que ce pouvoir
a fait porter l'effort sur les petits
retraités sur ce qui ont été licenciés à
55 ans qui vont devoir travailler
jusqu'à enfin être au RSA jusqu'à 64 et
c'est à dire les 7 milliards d'économies
les seuls économies prévues pour dans
sont faites sur les plus modestes je
trouve ça absolument
ça c'est le quoiqu'il en coûte de la
crise c'est autre chose je parle
maintenant les mesures maintenant les
seules mesures d'économies qui sont
prises ont été faites sur les plus
modestes sur aussi le dispositif des
logements
le gouvernement n'aide pas les plus
modestes et le gouvernement fait
souffrir toujours fiscalement les plus
modestes les classes moyennes et
favorise les plus riches tout le monde
le sait et regardez deux milliards ont
été à nouveau économisés sur le logement
alors qu'on a une crise du logement
absolument dramatique
avec un problème économique donc c'est
un pouvoir qui est tellement injuste
vous savez moi je suis pas Monsieur
Mélenchon je suis pas pour égaliser tout
mais là vous savez si on continue à
avoir une baisse de pouvoir d'achat
avoir une crise du logement à avoir
toujours des mesures qui tapent sur les
plus pauvres il y aura là aussi une
explosion et je ne comprends pas comment
on peut faire ça Christian Estrosi on
passe un tout autre sujet on parle de
laïcité Christian Estrosi a dénoncé les
prières musulmanes dans la cour de trois
écoles de sa ville de Nice prononcée par
une quinzaine d'écoliers le ministre de
l'éducation nationale papenja les a
qualifiés d'intolérable d'atteindre très
grave au principe de laïcité il annoncé
l'ouverture d'une enquête administrative
il a une bonne réaction de ministre le
ministre il sert à rien donc il ferait
mieux de partir le plus vite possible
c'est dramatique
à part
enfoncer des portes ouvertes vraiment
c'est tous les Français ont compris qui
ne faisaient rien voilà donc il doit
partir il doit partir au plus vite
j'espère que dans le remaniement il fera
partie du parce que
vous savez
moi j'écoute j'écoute je l'ai écouté
parce que je me suis dit tiens type qui
a un grand savoir qui a l'air compétent
et tout mais quand vous quand vous
écoutez vous comprenez qu'il fera rien
il y a jamais un truc clair c'est jamais
clair alors comment vous répondez
comment vous aurez répondu voilà de
Christian et
d'abord il devrait pas y avoir d'appel
de Christian streusy parce que c'est
tellement évident
que le système de l'éducation nationale
doit être remis sous tension mais pour
ça il faudrait qu'il y ait des ordres
clairs il faudrait que ce soit pas le
pas de vague on ouvre le parapluie et
que dès qu'un enseignant dit quelque
chose il est pas ça hiérarchie qui lui
dise tais-toi c'est pas grave parce que
c'est ça aujourd'hui la ligne dans
l'éducation nationale c'est je connais
bien parce que dans mon département
l'Essonne on voit ce qui se passe c'est
que dès qu'un enseignant veut être
respecté dès qu'un enseignant tire la
sonnette d'alarme la hiérarchie lui dit
pas de vague surtout pas de vagues voilà
et si Christian Estrosi n'avait pas dit
personne n'aurait jamais su donc ça veut
bien dire que le ministère ne fonctionne
plus
un dernier mot Fabrice oui cet
après-midi vous serez en Normandie dans
la France et dans le Calvados dans le
cadre de votre tour de France des
solutions la campagne 2027 a déjà
commencé pour Nicolas Dupont-Aignan non
non
en revanche c'est vrai que debout la
France sera présents européenne sur une
liste pour l'indépendance nationale
parce que
ça sera peut-être élargi j'espère
ceux qui voudront
je veux d'abord
des idées je crois qu'en politique les
idées nous avons pour les projets sur
l'Europe je propose un projet
j'allais dire radical c'est à dire je
crois qu'on arrive au point où il va
falloir choisir entre le fédéralisme
supranational c'est ce que veut Emmanuel
Macron c'est clair son projet est clair
la fin de la France comme État libre et
la France sera un gouvernail
est-ce que vous discutez avec Eric je
discute
on discute pour l'instant avec personne
je travaille sur le fond je présente un
projet et après vous souhaitez pas
forcément la concurrence
on ouvrira vous verrez chaque chose en
son temps d'abord vous me permettez
d'aller sur le terrain département près
département 20e département cet
après-midi l'Orne ce matin à Calvados et
orne non manche et Calvados pardon
Saint-Lô Evire pas à pas ce que je veux
c'est que je trouve par an oui parce
qu'il ferme un collège là c'est
dramatique et je vais soutenir les
parents d'élèves et puis au-delà de ça
écouter expliquer
affiner le projet parce que je crois que
la vie politique c'est pas des écuries
c'est pas des parties c'est des idées et
après de se
transformera ça est-ce qu'il y aura des
candidats de boule à France au
sénatorial très peu puisque nous n'avons
pas et je sais pas encore combien de
départements quelques départements mais
le scrutin sénatorial c'est un scrutin
différent c'est un scrutin
je crois ou il faut pas avoir une vision
obligatoirement très
partisane et politique chez vous dans
les salles il y en aura
dans quel département alors
ça laisse beaucoup de questions en
suspense
invité on passe au club des territoires